à quelques heures de l'investiture de
joe biden le dispositif de sécurité est
inédit et le niveau d' alerte et
maximales ici à washington 25 mille
membres de la garde nationale venus des
quatre coins des états unis pour
sécuriser la capitale fédérale c'est
approximativement quatre fois plus que
le nombre de troupes américaines
actuellement déployés en irak et en
afghanistan
il ya également ces barrières qui ont
été érigées autour de cette fameuse zone
rouge la zone qui abrite les bâtiments
officiels dont le capitole et dont
l'accès est strictement réservé aux
personnes autorisées
un nombre de personnes accréditées
fortement restreint cette année d'une
part à cause du contexte sanitaire et
d'autre part à cause de la menace qui
plane autour de l'investiture de joe
biden seules quelques personnes pourront
assister et deux près à cette cérémonie
joe biden devrait arriver aux alentours
de 11h heure locale 17h heure de paris
pour ensuite prêter serment et être
officiellement intronisé comme le 46e
président des états unis à défaut
d'avoir des spectateurs je baille donne
aura face à lui
190 milles drapeaux des drapeaux
américains mais aussi ce qui représente
les différents états du pays et qui
seront placés sur la pelouse qui se
trouve devant le capitole pas de parade
non plus cette année comme le d'habitude
la tradition joe biden se rendra
directement du capitole en direction du
cimetière militaire d'arlington pour
rendre hommage à la tombe du soldat
inconnu et puis sous escorte militaire
il se rendra à la maison blanche un
programme millimétré et la police locale
la gare nationale et le cycle à ce
service 10 se tenir prêt pour toute
éventualité et pour toute forme de
menaces